5g has the potential to ping Britain
into the future but what is it why is
everyone talking about it and should the
UK be using it essentially 5g is
superfast
mobile internet think of the data your
phone uses and then imagine it far
faster much less likely to disappear
when you're at a music festival the
reason it could be so revolutionary is
because businesses and new technology
will be able to rely on it there's no
reason why we shouldn't have
technological progress here in the UK
here's an example some groups say 5g is
the only way to make driverless cars a
reality so according to them if future
you wants to commute in a driverless car
you're going to need 5g I'm nervous but
I'm excited at the prospect let's
compare how a driverless car might work
with 5g and with 4G which is what we
currently use 5g works in near real-time
there's no lack so cars heading down the
same Road would be able to coordinate
their exact speeds and positions as they
go that means that if the car in front
suddenly swerves your car could swerve
too and avoid a crash in a 4G world
there may be a lag even if it's small
and in this scenario you can't afford a
lag the difference between swerving
immediately and swerving a few seconds
late could be fatal 5 G's potential
isn't just about speed it can also do
things like facilitating platooning
which essentially means it can make
different objects work together it also
has more capacity so in a packed out
crowd of people everyone will be able to
go online
the problem is 5g also has the potential
for harm there are two worries that
people are talking about the first is
that it's been created by a Chinese
company called Huawei Wow his
involvement in building our 5g network
will require concrete assurances about
the integrity and safety of the network
their controversial because people
accuse them of spying for the Chinese
government some experts worry they may
build backdoors into the technology that
would give China access to the world's
5g infrastructure we need
become more cyber Brazilian the idea is
not keeping the bad guys out keeping the
good guys in it's about how do we act in
this day and age with technology
advancements to make sure that we're
mitigating the risks the UK government
has decided to involve them in the
country's 5g anyway but to limit their
role
for example while way will be excluded
from sensitive areas such as nuclear
sites and military bases the company has
a big presence in the UK's tech
infrastructure already and the
intelligence agencies believe Huawei
presents a manageable risk this isn't
necessarily what the public wants only
14% of Brits agree with the UK using
Huawei to build 5g infrastructure the
second worry is about health even though
the government and experts say 5g will
have no impact on health some
campaigning groups are concerned it may
increase the risk of cancer 5g is
already in use across the UK but we're
yet to see the full potential of the
technology and the impact it could have